et avec nous pour cette demi heure
spéciale autour de valéry giscard
d'estaing didier moss bienvenue vous
êtes constitutionnaliste président
émérite de l'association française de
droit constitutionnel et président de la
société d'histoire de la vème république
roland cayrol bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes politologue directeur du
centre d'études et d'analysés directeur
de recherche associé au cevipof
vous avez publié l'année dernière le
président sur la corde raide les enjeux
du maquereau nisme sera avec nous dans
quelques secondes gérard longuet
sénateur a l'air de la meuse qui a
d'ailleurs été député sous l'ère giscard
à partir de 1978 et fabrice d'almeida
est également avec nous bien venu vous
êtes historien et professeur à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
hauteur de archives secrètes désarmé
merci à tous les quatre roland cayrol ça
vous paraît complètement saugrenue ou
plutôt pertinent de faire un parallèle
entre emmanuel macron et valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est toujours exagérées de
faire des comparaisons dans des périodes
où le pays est si différent où la
structure politique mais plus la même
alors évidemment il ya des choses qui
saute aux yeux donc ça ça me fait penser
lorsqu'il était lui valéry giscard
d'estaing est le plus jeune des
présidents de la république 40 jamais
élu en france 48 ans alors là il a perdu
son record
emmanuel macron il est de ceux qui ont
essayé de moderniser la politique
française c'était aussi un des objectifs
de macron bref il ya des choses qui qui
ressemble la façon de faire campagne
aussi un peu on à dire à l'américaine
marquée par la victoire de kennedy en
1960 tout ça fait que l'ia dans les
personnages quelque chose qui peut se
ressembler mais ni la conduite de la
politique ni à vérité les hommes ne ne
sont tout à fait comparables
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même pas mal
de deux points comme un élève brillant
tous les deux énarques tous les deux
inspecteur général des finances sous les
deux ministres américains
avant d'accéder à l'elysée didier moss
valéry giscard d'estaing d'avoir été
polytechnicien avant d'être à sec
ena et inspecteur général des finances
donc c'est quand même une différence
importante et j'allais dire sa formation
scientifique est resté très présente
jusqu'au jusqu'à aujourd'hui à dire un
certain nombre de ces discours sont le
témoignage de ce qu'a été sa forme de
pensée pour réussir ce grand concours de
l'x alors c'est vrai qu'on peut faire
des comparaisons mais vous savez qu'il
ya un vieil adage un comparaison n'est
pas raison
et moi je crois qu'il faut pas pousser
trop trop loin là la comparaison je
dirais simplement une grande différence
est que valéry giscard d'estaing havrais
parcours politique avant de devenir
président de la république il devient
président de la république en 1974 il a
été élu député en 1956 ce qui quand même
appris jaillir ce qu'est la vie
politique
bon il a été secrétaire d'état il a été
ministre il a été mis à la porte
il est devenu président de la commission
des finances il est revenu à dire et
avril la forme il a formé et fondé même
à partis politiques puis des clubs etc
c'est pas du tout l'ovni emmanuel macron
qu'on a vu débarquer
d'un seul coup et je crois de ce point
de vue là s'ils voulaient se l'objectif
de valéry giscard d'estaing
on le sait a toujours été d'être
président de la république ça y'a aucun
doute et même les souvenirs de ses
parents souvent dans ce sens en disant
on l'a poussé à cela bon alors depuis
quand est ce qu emmanuel macron avait
l'intention de l'être
je n'en sais rien mais certainement pas
depuis l'enfance voilà fabrice d'almeida
lorsque emmanuel macron était lui en
2017 dans libération alain duhamel écrit
ceci sous un nouveau visage c'est bien
le giscardisme ce sont bien ses idées sa
méthode la rupture douce la jeunesse la
hardiesse l'europe
la personnalisation du pouvoir la
réinvention de la communication
politique on peut même soutenir la thèse
selon laquelle macron c'est la logique
du giscardisme poussé jusqu'au bout
c'est la république giscardienne en
marche
voilà ce que disait des journalistes
politiques en 2017 à tort ou pas
aujourd'hui
non il ya quand même vous l'avez
souligné dans votre sujet et même si
roland cayrol et didier mau ça y répugne
il ya quand même quelques petits points
communs je dirais presque des logiques
doctrinal commune les deux vous l'avez
dit sont pro européen les deux sont très
favorables en tout cas dans la première
partie du mandat d' emmanuel macron au
libre échange
les deux ont une logique dans laquelle
il suppose que la modernisation de la
société française peut venir par la
modernisation de l'économie française
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui explique que en
pleine crise
quand valéry giscard d'estaing va
solliciter raymond barre raymond barre
va faire une politique de l'offre une
politique de l'investissement et d'une
certaine manière le premier mac on avait
cette logique là avant qu'on passe au
deuxième ce qui celui qui n'est pas
seulement à cause du coc vida a revu la
question des équilibres économiques et
la question des frontières même donc il
ya un aspect doctrinale et puis il ya un
positionnement politique c'est à dire
que les deux arrivent un peu à la même
conclusion mais avec des idées
différentes
pour valéry giscard d'estaing il ya
l'idée qu'il ya deux français sur trois
il écrit un livre qui porte ce titre qui
se situe au centre donc pour lui
logiquement la majorité étant au centre
il doit pouvoir remporter les élections
pourraient maniema qu'on y est
j'ai des extrêmes un rejet des extrêmes
qui nécessite de se positionner ni à
droite ni à gauche et donc à nouveau
d'une certaine manière
même s'il ne le dit pas au centre et
donc les deux d'ailleurs pour compléter
la remarque didier moi tout à l'heure
les deux ont créé leur parti politique
puisque valéry giscard d'estaing elle
vient des indépendants puis des
républicains indépendants et il va créer
l'udf une fédération de partie emmanuel
mâcon créé lui alors effectivement main
giscard ne fait quand il est au pouvoir
macron le fait avant d'arriver au
pouvoir il va créer donc son parti en
marche situe au centre donc on peut
jouer la carte des comparaisons alors
après et pour vraiment complété mais on
y reviendra sur les charges au plus tard
il faut il faut non je me disais juste
après on peut compléter cette question
avec est-ce qu'ils ont des points
sombres commun alors le positionnement
politique d'abord on va s'arrêter sur
cette idée assez proches sur le papier
en tout cas c'est ce que vous nous dites
tous les deux au centre de l'échiquier
giscard venait du centre-droit macron
plutôt du centre gauche glanant des voix
à droite et à gauche tous les deux avec
les risques que cela comporte
on a posé la question à gérard larcher
ce matin sur france inter la réponse est
très net écoute et je pense que le
maquereau leaf c'est autre chose c'est
la définition du en même temps alors
qu'avec valéry giscard d'estaing
nous avions une vision une vision
européenne une vision d'une france au
centre qui parfois a pu faire
discordance avec la famille gaulliste
mais je n'oublie pas que valéry giscard
d'estaing fait avec les républicains et
indépendants dans les différentes
configurations
ils ont participé à la construction de
5e aurait pu gérard longuet compenser
vous le positionnement politique d'
emmanuel macron et celui de valéry
giscard d'estaing ont un lien ou n'ont
rien à voir
les personnalités sont proches parce
qu'il y a cette formation universitaire
cette formation grande école c'était
expérience du service public mais la
différence a été évoquée notamment par
didier moss valéry giscard d'estaing est
d'abord et avant tout un homme de la
politique il est entré très tôt dans la
politique
son arrière-grand-père son grand-père
bardou était un élu il a été élu jeune
député en 56 il avait 30 ans
c'est le gérard larcher a raison de
rappeler qu'il a fondée certes une
famille politique mais à partir de
famille préexistantes les libéraux des
indépendants là la démocratie chrétienne
le parti radical il est complètement
dans les formations politiques de la
quatrième et la cinquième république
simplement c'est un homme de la
quatrième qui acceptent les institutions
de la vème et dont le projet est
essentiellement un projet euro bien
alors leur point commun en dehors de la
formation c'est l'acceptation de la
dimension internationale de la situation
française
c'est l'un et l'autre pense la france
dans son dans sa dimension
internationale il ne se vivent pas
replié sur l'hexagone
roland cayrol ce positionnement
politique voilà comment ni un gérard
larcher en dix ans il y en a absolument
pas on a en même temps qui est plutôt
pragmatique et voire opportuniste alors
que valéry giscard d'estaing lui était
au centre mais par vision par idéologie
écoutez je voudrais rappeler notre ami
fabrice d'almeida que emmanuel macron
jamais dit ni de gauche ni de droite
jamais une seule fois il a dit hey de
gauche et de droite
il faut dépasser des divisions qui
aujourd'hui sont plus forcément
opérationnel et mettre autour de la
table des gens raisonnables qui pourront
se mettre d'accord sur une politique
ça n'a rien à voir avec ceux situés au
centre et vouloir élargir le centre ce
que ce que giscard comprendre et il
aurait toujours raison aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut essayer pour réformer en
profondeur un pays d'avoir la corde deux
français sur trois que si on n'obtient
que des majorités fusse-t-elle absolue
un peu riquiqui
ça risque de provoquer des crises dans
le pays ils sont en même temps deux en
europe à dire cela valéry giscard
d'estaing et le secrétaire général à
l'époque du parti communiste italien
deux partis qui dominent leur système
politique du moment et qui aspirent à le
dominer plus mais vraiment on est on est
pas du tout dans la même
gic ni de fabrication d'une majorité ni
de gouvernement ce sont deux façons de
voir les choses alors on peut dire que
ce sont tous les deux des modérés tous
les deux deux européens voilà au haut
niveau de banalités sur la politique oui
je crois que sur le fond même de la
politique ces deux expériences qui sont
tout à fait différentes
c'est normal de centristes quand même
deux femmes ont dit non non non non les
manuela gross nema dix entraînements ce
n'est pas du centrisme c'est une façon
d'essayer de mettre d'accord y compris
au gouvernement des gens qui restent des
gens de droite et des gens qui restent
des gens de gauche quitte éventuellement
à ce qu'ils jouent sur des pianos
différents la même partition mais ça
n'est pas l'idée de faire envahir une
vie politique par qu'un parti centriste
très kawaï la nuance est importante
effectivement didier mas au nom non mais
moi je suis totalement d'accord avec ça
et gérard longuet se souvient aussi de
cette période puisque nous avons le même
âge et que nous avons usé nos culottes
sur quelques bancs commun donc mais là
j'ai dit c'est pas du tout pareil quand
on regarde 74 et les années entre 72 74
quelle est la situation politique de la
france c'est la signature du vrai homme
commun de la gauche parti communiste
parti socialiste et rades et radicaux et
radicaux de gauche bon contre une
alliance de droite et jaillir le second
tour de 74 ne peut en aucun cas aucun
cas être comparé au second tour de 2017
emmanuel macron a gagné l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour en 2017
c'était pas du tout fait pour giscard en
1974 et même la marge était très étroite
donc je crois que travailler non plus
pour emmanuel même en 2017
le soir du premier tour il avait gagné
il avait gagné c'était évident il l'a
d'ailleurs je le souligne souvent mal
gagné par rapport à jacques chirac bon
parce qu'il a devant lui à ces deux
français sur trois mais il a quand même
permis à madame le pen de faire un
français sur trois ce qui est quand même
beaucoup très très honnêtement et donc
je crois que vraiment en termes de
positionnement politique en terme
d'alliance en termes de stratégie j'ai à
dire les deux n'ont rien à voir est le
dernier exemple on dit mais emmanuel
macron a créé à partie moi j'attends
toujours de voir will est ce parti la
république en marche on avant l'élection
présidentielle
un jour j'ai téléphoné et où j'ai envoyé
un message email au siège de dedans
marche de l'époque alors disant voilà
j'aurai savoir quel est le montant de la
cotisation ou bon parce que ça
m'intéresse entend politicologue je n'ai
pas spécialement la terre non je fais
partie d'une formation politique mais ça
m'intéressait armes a répondu il n'y a
pas de cotisation mais vous pouvez faire
un don et alors je dois dire que pour
moi un parti politique où il n'ya pas de
cotisation c'est pas un parti politique
c'est un club d'applaudissements je le
dis très franchement et quelle que soit
la sympathie qu'on peut avoir pour
l'action menée par emmanuel macron mais
ce n'est que c'est quelqu'un qui refuse
la notion historique de partis
politiques
rappelez-vous ce qu'étaient les
cérémonies de reprise des cartes dans
les formations de gauche dans le temps
les syndicats parti communiste parti
socialiste ont payé des cotisations
mensuelles pour est tellement c'était
important
c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui n'a
aucun sens dans la peau d'un sens de la
vie d'aujourd'hui est donc vraiment là
je réfute heureux l'analogie politique
je ne dis pas l'analogie personnel au
positionnement repères on est on est
tous d'accord là dessus macway valéry
giscard d'estaing sont des libéraux de
centre-droit un fondamentalement bon
mais du point de vue de l'analyse
stratégique et non strictement rien à
voire et c'est peut-être un point commun
qui peut difficilement leur être
contestée c'est leur amour et leur
engagement pour l'europe
regardez on est en juin soit forme 17
mai les giscard d'estaing revient de
londres où a été adopté la loi sur
l'élection au suffrage universel du
parlement européen et il en est très
fier écoutez je ne veux pas que la
france soit à la traîne de l'europe
une étape a été franchie
les institutions sont en place il faut
maintenant les utiliser pour faire
avancer l'europe
fabrice d'almeida ça c'est incontestable
emmanuel macron et valéry giscard
d'estaing tous les deux très pro
européens et pour une place importante
de la france dans cette europe
oui mais j'imagine que didier mau c'est
roland cayrol vont nous expliquer que
c'est très différent parce que à
l'époque y avait pas l'euro et qui avait
les culs je voudrais juste dire à didier
moss petite blague entre nous mais il
semble qu'au tout début
df ya pas de cotisation parce que c'est
des cotisations indirects qui sont
versés aux partis composante de l'udf
m'enfin c'est un détaillant rebond
politologue on peut passer là dessus non
mais effectivement quand même il ya ici
on essaie de réfléchir quand même un peu
à ce qui peut composer les masses de la
politique faut bien admettre tout ce qui
m'a été reproché dans le détail quand on
admet les masses de granit dans la
politique
qu'est ce qui définit notre politique
aujourd'hui pro-europe anti europe
là dessus on peut dire qu'ils sont
d'accord deuxième chose quand on regarde
à nouveau très interventionniste ou pas
interventionniste giscard et moins
interventionniste que nous les
maquereaux que ne l'est le deuxième
macron celui d'aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement interventionniste
peut-être que d'une certaine manière
giscard le regard logique le giscard
président de la république le regarderai
aujourd'hui avec un oeil à ces critiques
puisqu'il en fait beaucoup trop une
grosse différence aussi mais en même
temps petit point commun giscard reste
un homme qui pense l'équilibré
budgétaire il le déficit budgétaire et
l'endettement de la france commence à
cette époque là mais j'allais dire à son
corps défendant
alors que macron à on peut dire le
premier mac on avait la même optique
mais il en a changé donc je vois bien
comment mais mes camarades vont me dire
même sur la politique européenne
giscard n'étais pas partisan qui est une
intégration aussi profonde que celle que
nous avons avec la avec la banque
centrale même s'il y a contribué je le
rappelle ce que giscard a contribué à la
réflexion sur la création de la banque
centrale européenne et donc peut-être
qu'il regarderait d'un drôle d'oeil
cette manière que nous avons de
refinancer toute l'économie européenne à
partir j'allais dire d'argent inexistant
donc voilà je veux pas insister plus
parce que je sais que les amis
démocrates mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
sens c'est vrai qu'ils ont aussi en
commun de vivre une crise absolument
majeur valéry giscard d'estaing gérard
longuet va vivre le choc pétrolier et
ses conséquences emmanuel macron est en
train de vivre une crise absolument
historique et d'ailleurs ils ne vont pas
réagir de la même manière absolument le
choc pétrole le président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing au
moment du choc pétrolier veut protéger
la france et c'est lui qui va par
exemple mettre en place l'indemnisation
du chômage économique un taux de
le couverture de revenus qui est
pratiquement 2 90% et qui constitue une
véritable révolution sociale
l'action sociale de de giscard d'estaing
s'inscrit dans un contexte économique
qui est en effet plus difficile qui
n'est pas celui d'aujourd'hui mais qui
n'a rien à voir avec les amener qui
avait précédé immédiatement le choc
pétrolier et valéry giscard d'estaing à
ce contact veut protéger la vérité
protection lutte était sans doute
d'avoir une politique de l'offre
beaucoup plus dynamique
je voudrais dire une juste une chose les
deux sociétés françaises de 74 et de
2017 non simplement rien à voir quand
même vous rappeler qu'en 74 et même en
80 les banques les compagnies
d'assurances une partie de l'industrie
l'un sans appartiennent à l'état et
l'information
ça reste encore à l'exception de rtl et
europe des chaînes d'état
nous avions défendu jeune député madela
les otaries mois les radios libres
on était totalement minoritaire dans
notre camp donc va aller jusqu'à un
destin d'ailleurs on le voit bien dans
la gravité son expression
c'est vraiment le il incarne une france
assez étatiste et lui-même est en effet
un inspecteur des finances
interventionniste et il va intervenir
alors ça surprend beaucoup dans
l'économie dans les fusions dans les
regroupements industriels
il est libéral et girondins n'ont en
fait il ne fait pas de vraie
décentralisation
il faudra attendre gaston defferre et et
françois mitterrand non c'est ce sont
deux époques très différente peut
comparer les hommes par la vivacité de
l'intelligence par une forme de brio je
crois que valéry giscard d'estaing est
plus un chasseur qui keating et qui tue
macron est plus un philosophe qui
démontre la sab le mans jusqu'au moment
il son interlocuteur baissent les bras
et dit oui vous avez raison
comme vous le dites roland cayrol oui
moi je suis d'accord avec tout ce que
vient de dire
gérard longuet projet m'intéresse plus
de parler de giscard ce soir que de
parler de maquereaux on aura d'autres
moments il me semble que il ya une chose
que les gens qui se réclament
aujourd'hui encore du giscardisme il ya
une chose qu'ils ont beaucoup dit toute
la journée c'est son apport extrêmement
important sur le plan sociétal peut-être
qu'on y viendra
je sais pas si sûr bon alors si on a
bien ça disons d'un mot le la loi contre
l'avortement l'un de la majorité à 18
ans le divorce par consentement mutuel
il ya plein de choses qui sont des
avancées de modernisation de la société
française que giscard construit en plus
largement contre une bonne partie de sa
propre majorité
et ça il convient de le rappeler parce
que c'est un acquis tout à fait
important du giscardisme mais y'a une
chose je trouve que les économistes
giscardien souligne pas assez depuis ce
matin c'est que malgré les deux chocs
pétroliers de 73 et 79
il ya un autre acquis du mandat de
giscard d'estaing c'est que les
inégalités sociales vont être amoindrie
pendant ce quinquennat pendant ce
septennat plus que par aucun autre
mandat présidentiel
c'est sous giscard que grâce aux
indemnités
grâce aux cotisations enfin aux oraux
aux aides sociales considérables qui ont
été accordées malgré les crises
on a une réduction des inégalités entre
d'une part les veuves
les ouvriers les handicapés et les plus
riches des revenus français mais dites
moi si je me trompe c'est bien sous son
mandat qu apparaît aussi un phénomène de
chômage de masse alors j'évite reste un
parti vient mais les inégalités c'est
très important et c'est un des combats
de ces opposants qu'ils perdront car
sous les deux mandats de mitterrand les
inégalités vont se recroiser en revanche
en effet apparaît le chômage de masse
chaud jusqu'à requis rassurez-vous sera
doublée dès le premier mandat de
mitterrand des mitterrand et mitterrand
est élu contre giscard
là c'est l'ancien sondeurs qui vous
parle il est élu sur le problème du
chômage
les courbes des deux hommes se croisent
à la main au milieu de janvier lors de
l'élection à lui au printemps en mi
janvier ils se croisent et le seul items
comme disent les sondeurs sur lequel
mitterrand l'emportent désormais sur
giscard c'est la capacité à résoudre la
crise de l'emploi donc giscard va perdre
sur l'emploi est-ce que c'est sûrement
pas sa politique seul qui est
responsable de l'emploi c'est sûrement
aussi l'environnement international et
européen
mais encore une fois ne faisons pas
comme si à col de la loupe du chômage
qui est quelque chose qui restera
ensuite son avantage pour les français
il fallait oublier qu'il a y compris sur
le plan social une action assez
largement positive fabrice d'almeida
comment vous voyez cela effectivement
sous vge une réduction considérable des
inégalités sociales
c'est vrai que c'est c'est vrai qu'à
cette dimension et puis à cette
transformation c'est elie cohen qui
avait utilisé cette formule de l'état
brancardier c'est à dire l'état qui
vient au secours des entreprises qui
sont en train de licencier et ce
j'allais dire l'accord entre giscard et
chirac pour mettre en place une
assurance chômage qui indemnise
largement les français de manière à
éviter ce qu'il redoutait tous c'est à
dire un nouveau mai 68 une explosion
sociale
mais il ya un aspect quand même con
qu'on passe un peu sous le silence si on
veut faire une comparaison
et au risque d'écorner un petit peu la
mémoire du duc du président giscard ya
quand même eu sous son septennat
énormément de ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque des affaires et c'est vrai que
belle même si aucune et est directement
en relation avec
oui même si on peut penser que l été
elle était beaucoup plus complexe qu'on
imagine la sphère de breuil par exemple
a été un élément de un élément de
cristallisation de l'opinion sur l'idée
que la justice n'était pas indépendante
ministère de l'intérieur pour une peau
nette hausse ce qui serait intervenue la
sphère des diamants on en a beaucoup
parlé ces derniers temps mais cette
dimension là je crois à jouer pour
donner une image un petit peu négatif
puis à le dernier point il ya deux
points qu'on n'a pas abordé quand même
et qui naissent à cette époque là qui me
paraissent cruciaux et à celui de
l'immigration
le dossier de l'immigration giscard
avait il fait à la fois alors le
rapprochement familial
mais en même temps il a en tête l'idée
d'un retour des immigrés dans leurs pays
de départ et il organise l'arrêt de
l'immigration avec cette hypothèse que
peut-être en donnant de sel on disait un
petit pécule de dix mille francs
on réussira à faire partir certains
d'immigrés notamment en afrique du nord
et puis deuxième clé après je me tais
c'est la question de l'insécurité et de
la réponse policière
et c'est vrai que la loi sécurité et
liberté qui a adopté la loi perfide qui
adopte en 81 elle crée quelque chose qui
encore aujourd'hui est un abcès de
fixation dans le débat public qu'est la
question du contrôle d'identité
et c'est vrai que c'est de cette époque
que ça vient et je trouve que quand on
fait le bilan du giscardisme ya toute la
dimension moderne et il ya cette
dimension là qui est un peu différente
qui renvoie à une certaine conception de
l'ordre et du maintien de l'ordre qui me
semble plus héritière des années 60
voire même des années 50 dans la phase
coloniale que de quelque chose d'une
société très ouverte et on oublie aussi
de dire que giscard à affronter le
terrorisme lui aussi puisqu'on avait
déjà à cette époque le terrorisme moyen
oriental qui frappait en france pour
revenir sur le point sécuritaire c'est
vrai que certains ont même parlé d'un
virage sécuritaire lorsqu'il promulgué
la loi en 80 février 81 loi sécurité et
liberté
concocté par alain peyrefitte non mais
c'est vrai qu'un virage sécuritaire mais
le virage sécuritaire
il découle des événements
c'est pas un programme politique en soi
au moment où on est élu c'est une
réponse à une demande sociale et une
demande d'attentats comme cela était
ensuite par les uns et par les autres
quelquefois ça marche quelquefois ça
marche pas on est quand même obligé de
constater qu'on a eu de réponse réponse
réponse est que ça n'a pas beaucoup ça
évolue lui l'a fait mais c'est vrai
quand même qu'un vente est un délit qui
est qui et d'attribuer aux organisateurs
des manifestations
son espace dans la manifestation c'est
ce ne sera plus jamais faire ça non non
non mais ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que
j'ai valéry giscard d'estaing a ouvert
le conseil constitutionnel à
l'opposition du point de vue des
libertés et j'allais dire tout le
mouvement de constitutionnalisation
monkey et a été mon pain quotidien
pendant longtemps des libertés
fondamentales c'est à valéry giscard
d'estaing pour qu'on le doit et dire
tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
n'aurait pas vu la question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité s'il n'avait pas
eu dix ans 1074 l'ouverture du prétoire
du conseil constitutionnel et ça ça a
été très très bon et on l'enterrait la
véraison tout à l'heure de rappeler
l'été 74 avec bon là la mise en place de
faim le projet de loi sur les vg
l'abaissement de la majorité et un
certain nombre de choses comme ça et
c'est l'époque où je me souviens le
nouvel observateur se demander s'il
fallait pas et giscard dhien 1 voilà
alors quand on dit ça aujourd'hui on se
demande mais c'est la deuxième gauche a
été disons un petit peu prise dans le
piège giscard pendant quelques mois
peut-être pas très longtemps mais ça a
duré au moins l'été l'automne 74 et
gérard longuet oui alors il a rebaptisé
cas je me rappelle qu' il nous avions
dans notre majorité giscardienne et
compris d'ailleurs à l'udf un certain
nombre d'anciens membres de la sfpi you
du parti socialiste qui n'avaient pas
suivi le programme commun qui n'avaient
pas suivi l'alliance à gauche je pense à
oumé en 2000 où je pense au maire de
saint-etienne et il ya eu cette
ouverture qui correspondait d'ailleurs à
une dimension sociale qui a été
heureusement souligné et j'évoquais
l'indemnisation du chômage les personnes
âgées et handicapées ont véritablement
bénéficier d'un changement d'attitude
d'un changement
deux regards à cette époque en revanche
il ya un aspect personnel de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui pour nous qui
étions très giscardien nous a un peu
déconcerté parfois même gêné c'est une
attitude qui s'est un peu un peu
erratique
c'était un jeune homme brillant
séduisant sportif jouant de l'accordéon
chantant s'il le fallait
lorsqu'il était candidat à la présidence
est assez rapidement après la rupture de
76 et 77 on a vu d'ailleurs cette
intervention on a l'impression d'un
homme qui n'est pas heureux finalement
dans l'exercice de son mandat et qui n'a
plus la la joie qui était la sienne
lorsqu'il était candidat et je pense que
ça explique en partie 81 le sentiment
d'une attitude personnelle défensive
alors qu'il avait un très bon bilan et
de bonnes raisons de ne promouvoir ses
actions sans complexe peut-être était-il
plus heureux lorsqu'il était élu local
et et maire de chamalières merci en tout
cas merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette demi-heure spécial
valéry giscard d'estaing fin de cette
émission on se retrouve lundi à 18
heures et à 22 heures en attendant vous
retrouvez bonjour chez vous dès 7h30
pour une émission spéciale la matinale
se délocalise à clermont ferrand
oriane mancini recevra alors qui est
président du conseil régional d'auvergne
et rhône-alpes je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]